[Musica]
questa sera insieme faremo un viaggio in
questi pochi minuti conquistano insieme
sarà un viaggio insieme alle vittime
della nostra ricchezza
queste persone saranno i nostri compagni
in questo vagone di terza classe che
attraverserà la filiera del materiale
tecnologico
partendo dalla repubblica democratica
del congo dove viene raccolto un
minerale chiamato a coltan che è
presente in tutte le nostre tasche
presente nei cellulari nei tablet e
prima ancora all'interno dei forni
microonde delle turbine a elica questo
minerale ci serve per condurre una
fortissima energia in uno spazio
piccolissimo quindi è presente
ovviamente in piccolissime quantità
all'interno di questi circuiti questo
viaggio termine ora di nuovo in quale
regione del mondo che l'africa
esattamente nella zona del ghana dove
vanno a finire la maggior parte dei
nostri materiali tecnologici in disuso
quindi in una delle più grandi
discariche tecnologiche del ghana del
del mondo che si trova ad accra capitale
del ghana una discarica chiamata a globe
lo sci quindi vi invito a chiudere gli
occhi per qualche secondo e ad entrare
in questo vagone di terza classe e
riaprirli una volta che siete dentro le
vittime della nostra ricchezza sono
quelle persone che sono state sfruttate
fin dal periodo del della conoscenza
della nascita della dello pneumatico
grazie a mister danno perché sfruttò
queste zone
fin dai primi novecento
tramite il caucciù e quindi this bosco
praticamente tutte queste zone quindi i
nostri compagni di viaggio sono anche
queste persone che vivono in queste zone
in queste questi campi profughi non
riconosciuti dal governo a ridosso delle
miniere di coltan in queste catapecchie
che sono però dell'enclave per loro sono
delle zone di sicurezza per scappare dai
villaggi anche solo 20 30 chilometri di
distanza da queste zone che sono
normalmente in causa ci sono sono
subiscono
violenze invasioni inaudite da parte dei
ribelli e persone che non sanno neanche
più per cosa si stanno combattendo per
che cosa stanno ribellando quindi sono
vittime di violenze inaudite che
avvengono costantemente in queste zone
del mondo quindi nel vagone di questo
treno troveremo alcune di queste persone
che vivono in questa zona
troveremo questo ragazzo che mi fa
notare come anche loro hanno dei numeri
civici
all'interno di queste tende troveremo
francisca sta davanti vicino al
finestrino che ci racconta ci fa notare
come quello sfregio è il ricordo di una
violenza subita sul suo corpo e della
morte del marito lei si è salvata è
riuscito ad arrivare in questa enclave e
ho trovato una protezione seppur
sommaria in questa zona
questo è un viaggio che noi faremo per
qualche minuto è un viaggio che io ho
fatto per circa due mesi e ne ho spesi
altrettanti per prepararlo per riuscire
a riportare nella valigia un racconto ea
mostrare ciò che queste persone hanno in
questo periodo vissuto le persone che
noi vedremo in questo viaggio
all'interno del nostro vagone sono
persone meno fortunate di noi questo
viaggio lo percorrono per tutta la vita
alcuni dei nostri compagni di viaggio
sono i portantini delle di questi sacchi
pieni di coltan allo stato grezzo quindi
ancora con delle macerie all'interno
sacchi che pesano fino a 20 30 kg e
percorrono strade sterrate di 45
chilometri dalla miniera da ranieri
nuovo fino all'ala
paese ma assisi che questa zona del nord
kivu al nord est del congo e le per
corona anche quattro cinque volte al
giorno per riuscire a fare qualche
dollaro
i nostri compagni sono anche queste
persone che scavano e raccolgono questo
minerale 12 14 16 ore al giorno perché
sono liberi di scegliere quanto lavorare
sono liberi di lavorare 24 ore al giorno
anche perché la miniera non si ferma mai
sono persone che escono dallo stomaco
dall'intestino di una terra di una terra
scavata e di una terra che spesso e
volentieri frana e per riuscire a
sopperire a queste frane utilizzano
delle travi di legno per cui
probabilmente noi non faremo neanche
delle mensole e queste travi dovrebbero
sorreggere la roccia che loro scavano
per riuscire a trovare il coltan più
puro sono persone come assad che spiega
come può essere difficile faticoso
riuscire a portare a casa quei pochi
dollari per far vivere la loro la sua
famiglia in una casetta di lami con i
tetti di lamiera anziché in una tenda
sono persone come questi ragazzi che non
possono permettersi di frequentare una
scuola non fanno neanche cosa sia una
scuola e si ritrovano a 14 15 anni anche
12 certe volte a scavare nella terra
oppure si ritrovano quelli più fortunati
a filtrare il colpa nel minerale dalla
terra grezza poi ci sono quelli più
sfortunati quelli più esili più graci di
quegli piccolini spesso hanno otto nove
dieci anni si ritrovano a scendere nel
nei meandri della terra anche 15 20
metri in dei buchi fatti in maniera
rudimentale del diametro di 90 100
centimetri
quando io chiedevo a questi ragazzi che
cosa stavano andando a recuperare se
sapevano che cosa poteva servire il
coltan quelle quel minerale che stavano
avendo ovviamente non sapevano
assolutamente darmi una risposta
ci sono poi nel vagone di davanti sempre
vicino al finestrino vicino a francisca
ceo detta o dettami fa entrare nella sua
tenda e mi racconta che un ribelle
l'anno prima non ha avuto pietà neanche
della sua menomazione alle gambe e l'ha
violentata
però diventate ha fatto nascere il
figlio della violenza ma ho detta dona
mora questo ragazzo a questo bambino poi
ci sono le vedove dei minatori o le
mamme dei giovani minatori che muoiono
muoiono costantemente nei crolli di
questa montagna perché quelle travi che
avete visto ovviamente non sono in grado
di sorreggere il peso di questi scavi e
sono queste donne che inizialmente
quando ti conoscono non sono in grado di
comunicare non si fidano hanno paura
perché i governativi nel momento in cui
si lamentano di qualche cosa possono
promettere loro di fargli fare la stessa
fine dei mariti non sono in grado di
recuperare il corpo dei mariti
quindi questi scavi queste queste
montagne così ricche ricche da morire
finiscano ad essere delle tombe per
queste famiglie però nel momento in cui
si aprono nel momento in cui si fidano
si accavallano tra di loro nel cercare
di raccontarti le loro storie perché
sperano che in quella valigia che
porteremo a casa quando torniamo ci
possa essere un qualcosa di utile per
divulgare l'informazione e poi arriviamo
alla fine della della prima della prima
nostra tratta di viaggio nella stazione
di gomme questa città frontaliera tra il
congo e ruanda dove
notiamo subito ci svegliamo da questa
prima parte di viaggio e capiamo che
anche lì queste grandissime questi
grandissimi pannelli pubblicitari
informano su come un cellulare può
essere importante anche nella
comunicazione di come il business deve
continuare a questo punto ho deciso di
farvi continuare in questo viaggio in
una seconda parte nella parte appunto
come vi ho detto prima doveva finire
questo minerale questo materiale
tecnologico dove dove vanno a finire
questi container pieni di prodotti di
seconda mano che spesso le aziende
caricano pensando di far beneficenza a
una terra come l'africa ma molte volte
lo fanno magari inconsciamente pensando
che costi di meno comunque fare
beneficenza piuttosto che smaltire le
cose in un posto in un luogo fatto
apposta per smaltirla in modo pulito
anche perché poi gli fanno notare questi
nostri amici della seconda parte del
viaggio che dopo 12 anni anche per loro
saranno obsoleti questi queste stampanti
questi frigoriferi questi cellulari
questi computer saranno obsoleti chi è
che dovrà sostenere i costi per uno
smaltimento pulito il governo ghanese
questi container arrivano in uno dei
porti più importanti del west africa che
si chiama tema tramite la mafia locale
col coinvolgimento anche di
autorità finisce spesso e volentieri in
questi inferni e in questo viaggio i
nostri compagni in questa parte di
viaggio saranno coloro che vivono quelle
70 80 mila persone che vivono
all'interno di queste discariche
tecnologiche qui alla mattina fisi si
sveglia osserva e cerca di raccogliere
qualcosa che possa risultare economico
per dal punto di vista anche del dello
smaltimento temporaneo è totalmente
abusivo di materiali plastici o di rame
o di materiali tecnologici in questi c'è
di sembra quasi un futuro distopico loro
lo vivono nel presente tutti i giorni
queste persone sono un pochettino delle
vedette di questi luoghi
questi i miei amici questo amico mi fa
notare mentre lo sto fotografando come
servizio a dio davanti a una
un panorama simile si avvicina
tantissimo al luogo che loro chiamano
sodoma e gomorra a globe lo sci per i
locali viene chiamato solo da mine
comore e quindi mi fa capire come
l'acqua di geni la quotidianità in
queste situazioni è fatta anche di
violenze come ad esempio questo nostro
amico sempre vicino a noi nel vagone è
stato vittima di una violenza da parte
di un gruppo di nigeriani di una banda
di nigeriani anche loro cittadini
abitanti di questa discarica perché si
pensava loro pensavano che avessero che
lui avesse rubato il dl del rame in
qualche filo di rame dalla loro riserva
lui ovviamente non ha fatto niente
affatto uno scambio di persona
semplicemente l'avevano ammazzato quasi
di botte e lui si stava disinfettando
come poteva poi c'è mohamed mohamed che
mi invita a casa sua dopo averci parlato
tanto mi invita a casa sua e mi fa
vedere come la sua casa come riuscita a
crearsi una casa in altra benigni usando
degli scheletri dei nostri frigoriferi e
poi non fa vedere la libreria come
riuscito a costruire una libreria e poi
c'è il suo nipotino che mi e
probabilmente non vedrà mai il cielo che
vediamo noi vedrà un cielo giallo un
cielo rosso e lui pensa che quelli sono
i colori del cielo o questi ragazzi che
sono di fronte a noi e se loro cercano
di affrontare la giornata scappando da
questo cielo da questa realtà
usando droghe
e poi c'è fitti fitti che orgoglioso mi
fa entrare nel suo atelier perché quello
è il suo atelier e mi mostra come lui
cerca in qualche modo di diventare un
designer di gioielli riciclati me ne ha
regalati alcuni
cercava in qualche modo di farmi capire
e di far capire a noi come poteva
diventare un qualcosa anche da indossare
questo oggetto di riciclo e fichi poi ci
fa vedere qual è la sua finestra la
finestra di casa sua questa è la sua
tenda oppure questo nostro amico che nel
momento in cui ha guardato i miei occhi
ha visto che c'è anche del bianco
attorno ai miei occhi e mi chiedeva come
mai la parte dei suoi occhi bianonera
bianca mera rosse e poi c'è questo
ragazzo con suo figlio che mi fa vedere
un po come si può vivere come una
famiglia può vivere come si può nascere
in queste zone del mondo
poi c'è questo ragazzo francis che
arriva dal nord della nigeria dal nord
del ghana e mi dice che ci racconta che
il suo sogno diventare musicista
arrivando nel nord del ghana ha cercato
nei paesi più poi non ha delle parti più
povere del ghana ha cercato fortuna
nella grande città che acra ovviamente
non trovando fortuna si è dovuto
rifugiare tra le 70 80 mila persone di
questo luogo insieme alla sorella sta
cantando un pezzo anni fa vedere che
anche bravo
poi c'è questo ragazzo che la sera
mentre stavamo chiacchierando accende
una televisione perché è riuscito a
recuperare un po di corrente della città
e quelle titolo undestanding time
il giorno dopo è un tetto ribaltato e
rashida mi fa capire come le case sono
delle istantanee in quel in quel mondo
poi la sera
vengo invitato da questo ragazzo a cena
e lui ne cucina come se fosse casa sua
come se fosse il terrazzo di casa sua
una pasta una pastina orgoglioso di
cucinare per me occidentale e phi phi
che prima di andare a dormire come tutte
le persone come tutti noi ci tiene a
lavarsi a farsi un bagno prima di
entrare in quella tenda che avete visto
prima con la finestrella questo lavoro
non vuole fare una denuncia una
fortissima ammonizione sullo sviluppo
tecnologico anzi abbiamo visto anche
prima che la tecnologia serve a noi
serve a loro anche per comunicare
serve più che altro per sensibilizzare
sensibilizzare in particolare le nuove
generazioni ad un
utilizzo ad un consumo più consapevole
e serve a far pensare a queste persone
che nel momento in cui è uscito un nuovo
cellulare
dopo sei mesi magari che noi abbiamo
comprato il nostro vecchio non siamo più
fighi se lo compriamo siamo
semplicemente un pochettino più complici
grazie mille
[Applauso]